Now we're going to talk about Islam.
And here we enter into a segment that in a sense is the most relevant if
relevance as a criterion sort of is a to today's world because these
controversies that play out today,
uh,
she ism versus Sunni,
for example,
uh,
the nature of Islam,
it's appeal,
uh,
as a religion on a world scale are obviously established in the period that
we're talking about.
They're established slow.
Like one of the things that you'll have noticed from the assignment is that the,
uh,
author Berkey emphasizes very much,
that Islam is slow information,
that it's not fully grown as this militant movement with a set of rules in,
you know,
six 32 the year that Mohammed dies.
And because of that,
then it's not to be understood as some militant conversion oriented jihad.
Oh centric religion from the start.
I said at one point when we were summarizing the end of the Roman Empire that
there were three heirs to the Roman empire.
One was the church.
Uh,
ironic because of the,
of course the church had grown up,
persecuted by the empire.
The other was the Byzantine Empire,
the eastern Roman Empire,
uh,
remember that it called itself the simply but Roman empire.
So that's the most clear claim being staked to succession,
to the Roman Empire.
And that the third was Islam.
And a couple of you said,
well,
Islam,
that's,
that's the most surprising of all actually.
And I didn't really elaborate at that time.
And that's not the center of what we're going to be talking about because time
moves on.
I remember in the seventh century,
the collapse of the Roman Empire in the West is a established,
um,
two and a half,
a two centuries earlier.
But,
uh,
Islam all though developed in Arabia outside of the Roman Empire.
And although very strong in places like Persia or the western part of India
would in many respects take up the inheritance of the Roman and Byzantine
Empires,
the,
uh,
conquests on the Mediterranean and the east.
And in the south,
it's architectural and artistic style.
It's administrative structure and not least the translation and elaborations of
Greeks,
science,
medicine,
uh,
and other,
academic,
uh,
forms,
including,
for example,
the translation of Aristotle.
And the influence of Aristotle would be,
uh,
signs of evidence of the significance of Islam within,
you know,
it's pointless to debate whether it's the western tradition or what the western
tradition means,
but within the classical legacy,
within what it means to say that Rome as a polity,
a ceased to exist in the west and yet the classical world has continued to
influence,
uh,
um,
society and ideas to this day.
So in,
in talking about the history of Islam,
one is inevitably going to be emphasizing,
uh,
it's um,
revolutionary nature.
And so I'm going to go against the reading in some sense or the reading is
intended to go against the conventional way of presenting the early history of
Islam.
And that can be sometimes annoying.
You know,
the,
the writer is a cautioning you against views you never had or the writer keeps
on saying,
well,
you know,
you,
we should not think that this,
and I hadn't thought that.
Just tell me what you think happened.
Uh,
in early Islam.
My apologies for that.
Writers are always writing against other writers.
The scholars are always riding against a prevailing interpretation.
Berkey is a continuous and that is the scholarly consensus now,
uh,
arguing against this notion of Islam bursting forth like some kind of pent up,
um,
uh,
explosion in Arabia.
But Arabia is off the map.
Islam as a movement and certainly the Arab conquest are uh,
unpredictable events.
They may be understandable later in terms of developments in the Near East,
both religious and cultural,
but up until the seventh century,
Arabia was on the periphery of the two great controlling empires to its north,
namely Persia and Rome.
And we are taking Byzantium as the air of Rome in this sense.
The problem with Arabia is that it is really dry and before the discovery of oil
or more precisely the,
before the discovery that of that oil was useful,
important and valuable,
it was a strikingly impoverished land in terms of natural resources,
a terrible land.
As Isaiah the Prophet says,
Isaiah 21,
one,
the burden of the desert of the sea as whirlwinds in the south pass through it.
So it cometh from the desert,
from a terrible land.
Now,
Isaiah actually grew up in what most of us,
we considered to be pretty dry circumstances.
The eastern Mediterranean Modern Day Israel,
Lebanon,
Syria are hot and dry compared to bounteous climbs like new haven.
Um,
okay.
Uh,
so the eastern Mediterranean however,
is a land of fertile oases river valleys like the fame Tigris,
Euphrates,
Fertile Crescent area,
uh,
coastal cities with commerce.
Uh,
yeah.
Where's Arabia
a is essentially a vast expanse of barely habitable terrain.
It is isolated by the sea on three sides.
It has very few natural harbors.
Okay.
There are no lakes,
no forests,
no grasslands even and no rivers that run year round.
Okay.
The only intrinsically favorable part of it is the south east,
South West Corner,
a modern Yemen.
Yeah.
This was in the ancient world,
or at least to the Roman Geographers Arabia,
Felix,
Happy Arabia,
Nice Arabia.
And indeed there were two kingdoms that emerged here around 1000 BC harbors
oases.
And these two kingdoms controlled the spice and incense trade from India and
from the Horn of Africa.
These are two extremely valuable kinds of products for religious gastronomically
and medicinal purposes.
Um,
and most of the spices come from India and most of the incense comes from modern
Somalia,
Ethiopia,
uh,
places,
along the Red Sea.
By the time of Mohammed,
however,
Southern Arabia,
his best days have passed.
And Mohammed is,
uh,
of course,
from,
uh,
central and in the sense of it's orientation,
really northern Arabia,
the worst desert in Arabia is the south.
So just when you get out of Yamen going North East,
you come to a,
an area that still bears the not really encouraging name,
the Empty Quarter.
Uh,
this is really serious,
no oases desert further north.
However,
in places like Mecca or Medina,
there is enough water for a settlement though not enough for agriculture.
A key event in the history of Arabia is the domestication of the Cammo,
which can be situated around 1000 BC.
Okay.
Arabia,
outside of the Yemenite kingdoms was mostly nomadic.
Though there were trading cities of which the most famous,
our Mecca and Medina,
these cities were rather cosmopolitan.
They had Arabs and other people's,
they had Christians,
some of whom were Arabs,
some of whom were not,
and Jews,
many of whom were also Arabs.
They controlled overland trade again from further east bearing exotic products
like spices from India,
organizing caravans.
Yeah.
Uh,
times they would form kingdoms.
At times there would be Arab kingdoms in the north,
but generally these are feuding.
Society's organized along tribal lines,
looked at from the Roman or Persian.
Empire.
Arabia was a little bit like the forests of Germany,
a hostile terrain from the Roman point of view,
person point of view,
inhabited by useful,
but presumably barbarian and presumably not very interesting.
Paintball,
this is the point of view of the Bible as well.
They're primitive people bearing interesting products inhabiting a land that's
not worth having,
not worth invading,
not worth owning,
not worth dealing with.
The first mention of Arabs seems to be eight 54 BC when according to a Syrian
inscription,
a certain,
uh,
Guindy Boob,
the Arab contributed a thousand camels to forces revolting against these
Syrians,
the Arabs,
hence forth.
After eight 54 I mentioned often in Babylonian and Persian texts,
they're always frontiers men or people inhabiting a land beyond a frontier
questions so far,
okay.
Not all Arabs are nomads,
but the Bedouin Bedouin in this sense,
meaning Arab nomad is sort of the or Arab,
the original Arab,
the defining archetype and the original colloquial meaning of the word Arab.
Uh,
in a way the better ones are a little like the Germanic tribes and analogy I'll
mention,
but I don't want to push too hard.
They form extended kinship units.
That is to say they know who their second cousins are and care about them.
Yeah.
And these extended kinship units form
a kind of tribal structure.
Okay.
This notion of tribe remains important to this day.
You'll have seen in accounts of post Qaddafi,
Libya for example.
The cliche and probably accurate is there is no tradition of government.
Kadafi didn't govern.
He just um,
tyrannized and there are no civil institutions.
It is divided by tribal loyalties.
What does tribe mean in math?
I actually don't know.
In terms of Libya,
it is a way of saying that people do not have loyalty to the state,
but to some extended kinship group or what's sometimes called fictive kinship
group.
I'm not really related to you,
but we have either the same name or we're from the same place or we consider
each other Ken and therefore have a certain protective sense about each other.
This is very useful if you don't have a government.
We've already spoken about this in terms of our question of what held
Merovingian society together.
Your second cousin becomes important to you if there's no police force,
if there's no way of making sure that someone's not going to kill you just for
fun or because they got angry at.
Yeah,
under the circumstances we live in,
we don't care about our second cousins.
We don't know who they are.
We don't expect anything from them in a society in which family is not just a
sentimental attachment,
but it actually is what is protecting your life.
Can ship is very important,
better wins as well as Germans.
Then the problem with kinship is that wall,
it's a very solid attachment.
It's also an irritant.
And here we're not talking about arguments over,
uh,
who's Christmas is better or who gets the Venetian glass vase,
after mom and dad's death.
We're talking about terrible arguments feuds that are within a kinship group.
So you have feuds within the skin,
uh,
groups or tribes and feuds between tribes accentuated in this case,
often by water,
water,
a scarce resource of the Asley and one that people fight about a lot in terms of
territorial feuds.
So the Bedouins tend to have more feuds,
um,
than the Germans.
There's no better when equivalent of their go.
Remember,
the variegated is the price that you have to pay,
uh,
um,
to make someone a half piece with you,
even if you've killed their relatives.
It's the worth of a person.
It's compensation.
And then other people can be,
um,
uh,
assessed on the basis of some tariff.
So women may be two thirds of a man.
Pregnant woman may be one and a half times a man and so forth.
We saw this in the Burgundian code key to the Burgundian code is this notion of
compensation,
that money related to the nature of the loss.
One finger,
two fingers,
right hand,
left hand,
uh,
is compensation better don't have that idea of compensation of tariffs of
Vericode in both.
The Bedouin in the German society is the ruler has a limited amount of power.
These are,
I wouldn't want to say democratic societies in terms of some theory of
representation,
but they're not societies in which one person well is obeyed unquestionably.
They are consultative.
They are more like gangs in that sense.
There's a leader,
um,
but,
uh,
his control is conditional on the loyalty of his most powerful subordinates.
And as most powerful subordinates are quite capable of overthrowing him,
the better one shake is a little different from the Germanic King.
And by dramatic king,
I mean not the kings that we've seen in the settled post Roman Merovingian
Empire,
but the Kings,
uh,
as described by Tacitus with,
possible,
greater or lesser accuracy in the Germanic tradition,
the king is a war leader.
In the better one tradition,
the shake is an arbiter,
uh,
a settler of disputes.
Both societies exalted custom and both had an exacting standard of masculinity.
Okay.
The Germans practiced agriculture and herded animals.
The better ones don't have agriculture.
Uh,
and they supplement their,
uh,
hurting of animals by raids on wealthier society.
These raids called Rasia,
uh,
are important
because the Islamic conquest that we're going to be star,
uh,
talking about on Wednesday may be said to begin as raids.
They begin as raids and then they discover that there's almost nobody there.
The army and the Persian army are a crippled by fighting against each other.
So what begins by raids becomes conquests.
Yeah.
So we come to Mohammed.
At first glance,
it would seem that Mohammad is a religious leader whose career takes place in
what a French scholar of religion called the full light of history.
Six twenties.
A D may not seem like the full light of history,
but,
uh,
Mohammed as a historical figure at least seems to emerge more clearly than
Abraham or Moses or Jesus.
But as you have read,
Muhammad's biography is hopelessly entwined with legend.
What we know about Mohamad is what later
Islamic and Arab commentators wanted to have happened to Mohammed.
Okay.
There are several sources for the life of Mohammed and four,
thus the early years of Islam.
There are formal biographies called Sera as Ira.
A problem with these is they were written long after Mohammad's death,
a hundred years at least.
There are collections of oral tradition called Hadi,
to which similarly there are sayings,
proverbs,
okay.
These are also questionable because although they were put together within 50
years of Mohammed's death,
they're very heavily influenced by the first civil war of the six fifties,
which we will be talking about,
uh,
the day after tomorrow.
And then there's the Koran,
the Koran.
Okay.
Which is supposed to represent,
uh,
the words of Muhammad,
as inspired by divine,
uh,
um,
well as,
as,
uh,
composed by divine inspiration.
Uh,
the Koran itself is a text that scholars outside of the Islamic tradition have
questioned in terms of when it was put together,
how much by Mohammed,
how soon after Mohammed.
Okay.
The problem with all these sources is not that they are unreliable in the sense
of fabrication,
but that they tend to shape events in light of what the writers already know
happens and in light of what they think should happen.
So that as an example,
uh,
we'll be talking about this in a moment,
but you're all aware that in six 22 Mohammed moves suddenly from Mecca to
Medina,
he maybe can be said to flee Mecca.
This is called the Hedgehog IRA,
or he's Ra in the a Berkey book,
H,
e j.
A or H,
I.
J.
R a,
depending on just how faithful you think you're being too.
The Arab original,
the head Gyra is a key event in Islamic history.
It is the point from which Islamic dating is done.
That is to say the Islamic calendar starts with the [inaudible].
So this year is the year of the hub Gyra such and such.
I can't do 2011 minus six 22 immediately,
but that's the Islamic year.
Right.
Okay.
According to the traditional historical record,
um,
the Meccans tried to assassinate Mohamed and he escaped a narrowly this attempt.
There's no real evidence of this degree of hostility on the part of people in
Mecca.
There's no evidence of an assassination attempt or at least independent
evidence.
And the assassination attempt seems to be something that is important for the
story,
for the way that the story is presented later.
Yeah.
To dramatize something that may not have been at the time as dramatic as it
seemed,
it may have been that the Meccans simply didn't listen to Mohammed and then he
accepted an invitation to Medina.
It may be that they are,
uh,
we're trying to sort of shut his movement down,
um,
but that they resorted to assassination does not seem to be a very likely.
Okay.
So having given you all of these fatiguing caveats about what we do and do not
know,
uh,
let's say Mohammed was born between five 70 and 580,
he was born into a reasonably,
um,
prominent but not really very affluent family of Mecca.
Yeah.
He may have been a merchant.
It is usually assumed he was.
And this is partly because the Koran has a lot of mercantile similes in order to
elucidate various points,
uh,
comparison is made with trade,
but there's no real evidence.
We don't really know what he did for a living.
We know that he married well,
his first wife,
Kardisha k,
h,
a,
d.
I n j a was,
uh,
from a wealthy family,
a higher class family,
then Muhammad's own.
And we also know that Mohammed got his start as a religious thinker,
as a profit at the age of 40,
on encouragement to those of us who are slow to get our careers off the ground.
The discouraging part is that his career only lasts relatively brief time dies
10 years after the judge had Gyra,
but he does accomplish an awful lot.
What was his religious experience?
W was the revelation vouchsafed to him that he preached to the citizens of a
mecca beginning around six 15 to six 20.
It is certainly a message of monotheism against what was considered to be a
prevailing paganism or polytheism on the part of the merchants and tribesmen of
Arabia.
But as we've said,
Arabia had lots of Jews and Christians as well,
and it's a little tricky to tell how much Mohammed would have known about
Judaism and Christianity,
but it looks as if he did.
And indeed it looks as if his preaching begins as a kind of biblical monotheism
for the Arabs.
It is a message to the Arabs congruent with the message of Judaism and
Christianity,
the message of Judaism and Christianity being understood as a,
uh,
statement of the unity of God and a progressive interpretation of God's message
by a series of profits,
a series of profits beginning with Abraham,
including,
uh,
Moses,
Isaiah,
Jesus according to Islam and Mohammed Mohammed is then in the line of profits.
The degree to which this means that Islam takes on its own identity is hard to
say.
And the tendency of scholars outside of the Islamic tradition that is people
like Berkey is to say it takes quite a while.
It takes quite a while for there to be the confidence that Islam is a religion
that is different from Judaism and Christianity.
Uh,
while it is clear from the start that the people who are embracing it are
different,
even though there are Arab and Jewish Christians.
And we'll see what that means in a moment.
Muhammad's first converts are his family circle and a group of key friends and
they're all important.
Historically,
his wife,
his cousin Ali,
who would marry his daughter Fatima.
Okay.
A merchant named [inaudible].
A powerful member of the,
one of the leading clans or family groups of Mecca.
Othman sometimes spelled I think in the Berkey book,
spelled with a u.
So we'll,
we'll,
we'll use the you Offman,
right.
Ali?
I've mentioned Abo backer
off button is a member of the EU Mayan family.
Okay.
And,
uh,
oh Maher,
these are sort of considered to be the inner circle of very,
very early converts.
As I said,
according to tradition,
the ruling circles of Mecca became fearful
as what had been a fringe movement started to gain more converts.
The people who ruled Mecca feared that there a control was slipping from their
grasp and they feared that this new movement was popular with a lower class.
The leading clan,
uh,
of,
Meco were the carriage
knees are the people who are most powerful in Mecca and begin as the enemies of
Mohammed and are responsible for driving him out if indeed he was driven out in
six 22,
the city of Medina,
another merchant center invited Mohammed to come as a kind of arbiter or ruler
who was above factions and who could then settle their internet scene disputes.
This is not an uncommon pattern.
You'll see it in late medieval and renaissance Italy in fact.
Um,
but Podo star in Italian cities is an outsider who is empowered with very,
uh,
extensive police powers to quell feuds in Romeo and Juliet,
for example,
there a postop,
but he doesn't,
he's not able to,
to solve the,
uh,
the feud.
But that's the kind of scene,
uh,
that we can imagine a as the western equivalent of Medina Mohammed is invited as
a wise man,
as an arbiter,
as a reconciler to the city of Medina.
An offer that he accepts
and it is in Medina,
is that we really start to see emerge,
uh,
what can be called in Islamic identity.
I tend to think a little bit earlier than Berkey because here Islam starts to
differentiate itself from Judaism and Christianity and indeed the period at
Medina culminates with the,
uh,
expulsion of Jewish groups who refuse to accept Muhammad.
Cool.
What he does at Medina also is to preach that the religious loyalty is more
important than loyalty to the tribal group.
The religious loyalty therefore is not simply a,
um,
accompaniment to your already existing identity.
It is the most important aspect of your identity.
Okay?
It's at Medina.
That Mecca replaces Jerusalem as the point of orientation for prayer.
It's at Medina that Mohammed stopped celebrating Yom Kippor and institutes a
month long fast
during the daylight hours.
Ramadan
at Medina Friday becomes the sabbath,
not Saturday or Sunday.
Okay.
And the Jews are expelled from Medina and by Jews I don't mean some kind of
foreign community of non Arabs who happened to be living in Medina,
but rather Jews,
some of whom came from elsewhere,
many of whom were Arabs.
And it's also here that Mohammed perfects this notion as against the Christians
and Jews who have scorned him,
that he is the seal of the prophets.
The last of the process.
Yes.
From Abraham to Jesus.
Now to Mohammed.
This is the last prophecy.
Okay.
God's message has not been packaged into one deal.
One a file,
you know,
too large for one email attachment and it's come in a bunch of them at this is
it?
Okay.
Here are all the cute cat pictures and all of the,
you know,
all the whole file which you now can download in segments,
but it's over.
This is the Jews and Christians are wrong to think that either it ended,
you know,
with Alijah or that it the be all and end all of all prophecy was Jesus.
No.
Okay.
No,
this is uh,
the truth.
But keep in mind that Islam did and at least is supposed to respect Judaism and
Christianity as not merely precursors,
but as part of the same tradition,
people of the book is the term often used in Islam to describe Judaism and
Christianity.
They share the same if not scripture.
Exactly.
But the same kind of historical religious orientation,
the criticism that Islam can make against Christianity is that it tends to be
polytheistic.
And as you know,
Islam expense great care to make sure that the human form does not appear in art
and in some forms of Islamic art that not even,
you know,
animals,
uh,
appear.
The depiction of the human figure is proscribed.
Great Care is made in differentiating Mohamed from what Muslim see as the
exaggerated stature of Jesus.
Muhammad is a prophet.
He is a messenger of Allah,
not to be identified with Allah himself.
There is no depiction of Muhammad.
People do not have pictures of him in their houses.
There are no statues to him.
Well,
Hammond's greatest challenge was to overcome these tribal loyalties in favor of
the Ooma u m m a the community of the faithful.
He allowed property in marriage to be decided still by tribal tradition,
but prohibited feuds and required that disputes be arbitrated in religious
courts.
This is important because Mohammed,
like the rabbis of the diaspora in Judaism is both a religious leader and a
judge.
He is a community leader and a spiritual leader and indeed these two things are
not really distinguished.
I emphasize this because it's really different Christianity.
In Christianity there's a church and there's a legal secular state sometimes and
of course the Middle Ages as time extent defined by this,
the church will have what looked like secular powers.
We've talked about this with regard to the bishops in Gregory of tour.
At times the papacy later would claim all sorts of political powers,
but conceptually in Christianity because Christianity was any illegal religious
brotherhood within the Roman Empire for uh,
uh,
over two centuries,
church and state are different.
Okay.
In Islam,
when can't really talk about church or clergy,
there are religious leaders who have political authority,
but their authority is what we would call that of a judge and that have a
religious leader.
At the same time,
the political order and the religious community are the same.
That's why when we talk about the Arab conquest or the Islamic conquest,
we're talking about something in which the new territories are taken over by a
state that's not a theocracy in the sense that the church is ruling the state.
But something in which the church and state are not to be distinguished.
We'll talk about this more when we come to the conquest within two years of the
Hud Gyra six 22.
So by six 24,
Mohammed was planning to take over Mecca to re enter in triumph the city that he
had fled,
if not under cover of darkness,
at least under murky circumstances.
A victory in battle in six 24 gave Mohammed the confidence to expelled Jews and
Christians from Medina
and uh,
to take on this title of Seal of the Prophets.
And by six 27,
uh,
uh Medina game,
the other upper hand and in six 30,
Mecca fell to Mohammed and his forces and all of the tribes of Mecca and of the
surrounding areas submitted to Mohammed.
They recognized him as a political as well as religious leader.
Again,
the two things not easily to be distinguished.
And then Mohammed died in six 32.
He died.
And what is remarkable is that the momentum he established was able to survive
his demise because most of the tribes probably thought that their loyalty was to
him as a prophet and a person and not to some sort of institution that would
survive his death.
And indeed his death would usher in a period of incredibly rapid expansion
within a few years of Mohammed's death.
Damascus,
the great city of the eastern Mediterranean,
the Byzantine Damascus would fall to the Arabs,
the first of many such conquests that we will be,
uh,
marching through on Wednesday.
But this question of religious loyalty would be exacerbated by splits within
Islam,
which will also be describing
okay.
The tenants of Islam,
just to close by way of,
uh,
our last remarks for the day,
Islam means surrender and to surrender oneself to the power of Allah is the
beginning of wisdom.
The beginning of faith.
Yeah.
Acknowledgement of Allah is acknowledgement of a strict monotheism
acknowledgement of Mohammed as the Messenger Prophet of Allah.
And as the last prophet.
Okay.
The so called five pillars of wisdom of Islam are duties.
Incumbent on the believer and these are the confession of faith that I just
mentioned.
Daily prayers five times a day,
the giving of arms.
Okay.
Be Observance of Ramadan and the performance of the pilgrimage to Mecca if
that's possible.
What's not there?
It's interesting to what's not.
Intrinsic to Islam is a strong sense of sin.
The
Arabs do not like the confessions of Saint Augustine.
They are not interested in this particular form of spiritual investigation.
Okay?
They're the believer can pray directly to Allah.
There is really no Islamic clergy in the sense of presiding over sacraments or
channels of grace.
The mosque is a gathering place.
It is not a place that has some kind of powerful holy objects in it in the sense
that a church in this era would have relics or eucharistic hosts and other very
powerful sacred things.
Islam is a religion of conduct and law,
not of mortification and purgation.
It emphasizes upright behavior.
No drinking,
no gambling,
certain dietary restrictions,
not than renunciation of the world.
It does not say sell everything you have and give it to the poor.
It says give arms.
It is a moderate religion actually.
It is a doable religion.
Okay.
These obligations may be somewhat inconvenient at times,
Ramadan,
for example.
But there is nothing in here to the degree that the New Testament,
for example,
prescribes behavior that most people are not going to follow
or the traditional Judaism possible,
but certainly a onerous,
lots of obligations.
Okay.
The other difference,
more important with Judaism is that Islam would be very quickly universal.
In other words,
it would encourage conversion,
although not as we will see,
um,
with great enthusiasm,
it is completely erroneous to think that these armies that burst forth from
Arabia after the death of Mohammad were intent on getting everybody to fall on
Mohamed.
They weren't tent on conquest.
All right?
But we'll see that their goals were a little more complicated than that of a
orienting everybody towards this new faith whenever we're going to call it.
And we'll see more about that today after tomorrow.
Thanks.